foreign
what are you doing
it's such a pleasure to speak to you
today I am such a fan I'm so grateful uh
it's a pleasure to speak with you what's
up
I've got a family situation that isn't
it isn't all that new to me but it's a
little bit new I am a grandmother of six
kids okay and I have a situation where
one of my sons went uh through a pretty
hard divorce last year it was a shocker
to him when his wife asked him for her
divorce and come to find out she was had
other interests
uh in another man and unfortunately has
went down just a horrible path and it's
been really hard on my son watching this
go on from the sidelines now
but in this process he thought that he
would try online dating and
did go out on some dates and
well I will call it fortunately but
Kim both of his acquaintances yes
acquaintances got pregnant one of his
acquaintances
that's the best grandma way to say that
one of his acquaintances one of his old
schoolmates
um okay so are you're going to be a new
grandma
gonna be a new Grandma okay and he's he
has wanted to be a dad Pro long time so
that is
my first very first thought when he told
me was oh my gosh you get to be a daddy
finally and I
I was genuine I am genuinely happy for
him I was then and I am now okay
the odd situation is that
since there wasn't a relationship before
the pregnancy
um neither one of them are pursuing a
stay relationship a couple relationships
afterwards and they've agreed to you
know be co-parents and she actually is a
parent uh she has two other children and
we've spent enough time with them that
uh she's an amazing Mama she's a very
generous mother when it comes to her
children's time spent with their dads
and I feel nothing
nothing bad about her at all because of
that I mean she's just she's amazing
so I guess my question comes in
what kind of boundaries
okay first of all I'm having a hard time
expressing to my son
what what my thoughts are about
his role to take with her I mean I I'm
encouraging I've spent time with them
with her kids
um
I just don't feel like he's connecting
who's he not connecting with with her or
with this baby well he's not connecting
with the baby he's not connecting he's
excited to be a dad I've we've been to
ultrasounds and that kind of thing but
he's not
he's not interested in what's going on
in the pregnancy really
and not
is shocking to me because he's such he's
such a loving loving man yeah I can I
can tell you I struggled with that and I
was married
I didn't know what I it was I didn't
know what to do I didn't know how or I
didn't know anything about what has
happened with pregnancy
and I didn't I had to go read up like I
didn't I just didn't know and so
ultimately I had to have some hard
conversations about hey I I've I'm on
the outside here right and I we lived
together and so I got to see the ins and
outs I didn't know what was happening so
I'm just trying I'm trying to just put
my my self in his shoes for a minute
to even I know somebody's pregnant I
don't fully understand what all that
means you know what I mean and I'm just
going home to my apartment every night
and I'm not living with this situation
and so I can I can imagine there's a
disconnect there or distancing
um do they go have coffee every once in
a while or whatever are they just going
about their lives when the baby's born
they'll figure it out
okay and
and what what you just expressed okay
that he doesn't get it I mean the most
recent pregnancy in our family that he
was around was his sister like 10 years
ago so
yeah and she probably is her third one
of these and so there's some routine for
her
um this is just what happens when you
get pregnant and so I can imagine like
whenever if you remember back the first
time you get pregnant it's all new for
everybody and everybody's talking about
it and thinking about it and reading
about it and getting opinions from
friends now this is this is her third
right and she's figuring out how am I
gonna be a single mom of three kids now
and manage these two men in my life now
or whatever
um and she's probably dating too like
right so it's a whole bunch going on for
her so I can imagine there's just a
distancing there it sounds like the
bigger picture here and if he was on the
phone I'd be having a whole different
conversation
the bigger picture is
you had a picture of what it would be
like when he had his first baby and this
is not it
and you were trying to navigate this
wild world where two adults decided to
hook up one night they had a baby and
they're like great we'll be great
parents see you later and you know
enough to know it's not going to work
like that over time
but also they're both good people like
it let me put it this way we have a
picture in our head of when couples
would do that that clearly they're
idiots or they are have mental health
issues or they're evil
and you're dealing with two adults who
are kind and rational and lovely people
independently and they are willing to
work together in the middle of a
situation they didn't plan but it's here
it doesn't fit the narrative right and
so we start spinning our wheels and then
when we start spinning our Wheels we
start trying to make other people do
things so that we can feel less spinny
does that make sense yeah
oh exactly exactly and I I can relate to
that although you know our other
children have been married and divorced
before and we I'm
I'm really close to those parents and I
think this one might just be a little
bit different just because I wanted it
for him for so long I think you're right
I think you wanted it for him for good
reason you sound like he's a good guy he
sounds like he's going to be a good dad
you want him for so long but you wanted
it in a context where everybody's going
to be safe and this one's going to be
this is going to be a lot of tightrope
walking without a net right
because there's not a safety of of a
relationship that when things get messy
which they will we can fall back on that
together we're just gonna have to fall
back on our good adult decision-making
skills which I don't know about you but
mine aren't always very great right
which is why the relationship is so
important like my my wife is such an
important role part of this process
um
I would focus on if I'm you I actually
what yeah what can I help you with like
how can I help
here I'm starting answering questions
you're not even asking
well
I think I think you're right on track
and boundaries have been an issue for me
before and especially with this son
I'm really
struggling to not jump in there and say
you know how can I help you for example
get the bedroom set up how can I help
you get ready for this baby
attempting that and no listen I just
thinking back
thinking this Baby's gonna weigh like
nine pounds they're gonna be 24 inches
long we don't need a room for it and
like say I mean I might as well be like
hey you just want to move to Mars it was
like my wife was like oh gosh I'm
married to a serial killer I was like
dude we could just like put it right
here in like next yeah what are we what
are we doing right but here's the thing
I didn't know
and if if
let's say my son
is
um married not married he finds out he's
expect he's gonna be a dad
I would and this is just the way I
handle problems is I would
um I don't see problems I had challenges
I would say cool from here until the
first year through the first that baby's
first year you have to have breakfast
with me once a week
I'll figure that out and so I would
challenge you to do that same thing with
him
okay I am wanna we're gonna have
breakfast I wanna hear what you're
thinking how this is all going I want to
I want to if you ever have questions for
me great and if we just sit there and
I'm gonna send you some questions for
humans cards we can just I just want to
get to know you better I I don't know
you very well I I've I think I know you
but I want you to ask me questions about
my life but no kid's gonna be like hey
Ma so when you're when the baby was
crowning right you're not no no son is
gonna ask his mom that but
in some of those questions for humans
there there's like what was the scariest
moment and you might be able to say when
that baby was leaving my body right and
he'll go oh gross you know I know it's
gross but right so they'll give you an
invitation into a conversation that
would be awkward otherwise to get into
um yeah but I think that's where you can
say okay let's let's paint me a picture
of what your home's gonna look like
paint me a picture of what you think
this will look like because those
diapers I had no idea
no idea
that a kid went through eight to ten
diapers a day
kid every second every second I had no
idea and so when they were like where a
diapers gonna go I'm thinking I don't
know like put them put one by the
kleenex box I didn't have any idea right
I didn't realize you had to have like a
back trucks up in the living room to
store all the diapers and that's just
for like a week and so I think just
saying hey but here's the focus not on
all of his deficiencies and where he's
not thinking you got to be thinking
about this not that
I love you and this is a scary time even
though it's exciting for you it's scary
time you got you're gonna have at least
one person always in your corner and
that's your Ma I'll be here in your
corner and
you have to have some weird
conversations normally you have them
with your wife you don't have that
luxury so you get to have them with your
mom all right and just kind of jump into
that a little bit and be really open
with him about saying if you don't want
to talk to me that's okay
and give him permission to walk away and
if he does that's his choice his as an
adult and it's gonna be really sad for
you and you're gonna have to deal with
your grief but you can't prop your you
can't make your son deal with your grief
right is that fair
yes
it's very fair and
I mean I think you hit all the nails on
the head I mean with boundaries being an
issue at various times in my life
I think that
being able to just focus on what is most
important to him
will help me not focus on
what what
exactly my perception was as to what his
life was going to look like have you
asked him hey what do you need right now
oh yeah
yeah especially since the divorce
because there's been it's been really
it's been really rough on him and
sometimes he just and he has said I just
need you to sit with me oh that's so
good yeah make that's so
so good and when moms sit with their
sons it's just I still like it when my
mom will just sit with me
and I'm I'm an old man I I still love it
and
she can also quietly ask me
hey are you gonna keep driving that car
because I think you're gonna die in it
right that's different than
you don't love your kids you're not
keeping them safe because you're driving
this little junky truck that that's a
totally different conversation so I
think in the moments when you're just
being with them and you're just sitting
with them and you can say
where's the bassinet gonna go
or
just for me because I'm a boundary free
mom
could I make a list of all the things
that I think I remember that you're
gonna need and we can start collecting
them now
whether that's a
a like a storage unit for all the
diapers you're gonna need or a bassinet
or a car seat
um I'll go to a parenting class with you
or I'll teach you how to how to change a
diaper on a doll right I had somebody
help me do that it was that wouldn't
awkward at all not awkward at all
helping deloney learn how to change the
diaper all those things right
and at the end of the day the picture's
different and so it's up to you to
adjust your picture because this is his
life
um and also you love him and you know
what's coming
he thinks he know his that he's just
gonna have a baby inserted into his
current life and you know when that baby
comes everything is different
everything is different and you know
that and it's hard to catch your breath
because you see what's coming he's about
to get hit in the mouth and you know it
and he's telling you Mom I'm cool I'm
I'm cool and you know you're not cool
so I'm just gonna hug you
and I'm gonna sit with you and when I'm
sad I'm gonna talk to my husband I'm
gonna talk to my counselor and talk to
my friends
and uh my son's not going to carry my
sadness that's not his job
he's gonna have enough trying to figure
out how to be a co-parent that's all
you're awesome Candace he's lucky to
have you lucky lucky to have you and to
all the parents out there whose kids
have made decisions that you don't
understand they don't make sense that
are dumb that are idiotic that are
lovely they're just different than the
way you did it
remember
their job is not to live your life their
job isn't to do everything the way you
wanted it done
their job is to be your kid and your job
is to love them even if that means hold
them accountable have hard conversations
I get all that
but most of us need love
and connectivity and then accountability
not the other way around